der ergebnissen die wir in der letzten
sitzung uns erarbeitet haben und zwar
hatten wir es da zu tun mit diesen mit
mir
sie kennen alle die man erkannt und wir
hatten da seine kritik der urteilskraft
und zusammenfassend können wir sagen
dass bekannt in dieser schrift eine
kritik der theologie unternehmen wissen
sie darüber was eine theologie ist das
bedeutet noch mal technologie wenn man
das jetzt immerhin schreiben was
bedeutet das wissen sie das noch
theologie was bedeutet das
das ist ein 2 ja also das auch nicht
genau das telos man denkt ja immer dass
wörter mit äußerst auf dem griechisch
milli sind die meisten sind ist aber das
können sich gut merken hier ist es
eindeutig als das tennis und der jura
wäre dann nicht erneut wie es
normalerweise bei wörter mit post ist
zum télé also ganz komisches wort also
das telos der zweck und das ist eben der
logos und das heißt einfach so viel wie
lehre oder auch ja theorie könnte man
auch sagen wobei die kirche nahmen
eigenes wort theorie dass sie so eine
betrachtung heißt das für heute mit
theorie gemeint ist das könnten wir als
team nie verstehen also das ist die
lehre vom zweck und vom zweck wir eben
sich in der welt finden vor allem in der
natur auf und kann kritisiert eine
auffassung von theologie wonach die welt
natur wirklich objektiv
sie verfassten und alle behandelten
denker vor kann gehen wir jetzt hier im
seminar schon diskutiert hatten also zum
beispiel herr da ganz zu beginn oder nur
mit bach unser freund der heute auch
wieder der mit grünen produkten sie
wissen schon
der heute auch wieder ganz kurz am ende
dieser
xr einheit zur sprache komplett und
natürlich auch goethe mit seiner
morphologie das sind alles theologen und
sie wissen wer als vater diesem
technischen auffassung gilt oder
aufregend sich die alle beziehen
das wissen sie das ist ganz klar das ist
niemand geringeres als aristoteles na
das ist der ist so der hintergrund auch
wenn die rede von filmen für frauen
spricht nochmal diesem ofen bibel güte
das bedeutet einfach nur die lehre
von tv die lehre von der v
das ist die machen ja okay wir haben
heute eine viertelstunde früher
angefangen wie der e mail geschrieben
und werden auch die fünf stunde früher
auf den aldi morphologie die ist auch
ganz stark bei interesse so und jetzt
sagt aber kann ein
in der natur gibt es nicht objektiv und
es gibt auch letztendlich keine
organismen derart dass sie von uns
objektiv als zeugnis ausgestattet
eingerichtet erkannt werden können
sondern wenn wir von zweckmäßigkeit
sprechender kannte sich bei katyn
subjektive zweckmäßigkeit das heißt
senken
die mäßigkeit mehr oder weniger in die
natur hinein urteilen muss ich sagen
mich in meinem denken sondern wir
beurteilung die zweckmäßigkeit gehen die
natur und die menschen
das ist ganz wichtig also es gibt eine
subjektive zweckmäßigkeit und kann kennt
nur ein weiter begriff nämlich dem der
mann zog kausalität und die er hingegen
also was in wirklichkeit hansa effizienz
so was können wir nach kant objektiv
behaupten und erkennen also nationalität
der ursächlichkeit äußere wirkung seine
mission die gibt es noch kein objektiv
die es nicht nur subjektiv sind nicht
objektiv hingegen zweckmäßigkeit also
organismen und telefonieren die ganze
geschichte
die existiert nach kann nicht objektiven
also nur subjektiv durch unsere
botschaft also natur qualitäten versus
zweck oder final kausalität theorie
müssen unterscheiden kann
theologie ist kann ein phänomen der
reflektierenden urteilskraft
also sagt etwas kauft über uns zu
urteilen und nicht so sehr über die
natur selbst
das wäre ein erkannt ein fehlschluss es
werde nach keiner nicht angemessen
das ist ganz kritische einigkeit ist ein
kritischer philosoph der hat alle
möglichen auffassung gibt es zuvor als
gültig gehalten
gültig angesehen wurden die hand geben
gut eine andere sichtweise den
entgegengesetzt und kant rekonstruiert
diese freiheit von der goethe sprachen
sondern ökologie diese freie des
organismus nah dieses selbst bezügliche
struktur die rekonstruiert kann
beurteilen ist theoretisch was jetzt was
jetzt genau dieses urteils theoretischen
auf sich beim blick auf diese tafel der
unseren seelen vermögen wie es hier
wahrscheinlich nochmal diese
verschiedenen vermögen habe ich drei
folgen kennt jetzt hier haben sie es
noch so gut aus diese tafeln auszulösen
welche drei vermögen gibt ihr hier
wir haben drei zuschauer
das ist schon sehr gut und wir haben
jetzt schon das dritte werk das ist auch
ganz toll steigern auf mindestens werden
das video von harald lesch was ich oben
rechts jetzt einmal hat schon 10.000
klicks
unglaublich da kann ich natürlich lange
nicht mithalten so aber informationen
auf diese auf diese vermögens
unterscheidung welche vermögen kennedy
zu schauen sie noch mal
sie kennt drei vermögen
wir haben also
verstand wirtschaftskraft dessen 77
und wenn wir von zig sprechen dann sehen
sie hier unter diese spalte prinzipien
abnehmen
das ist sie zweimal einen zweck gibt es
der ein vermögen zugeordnet einmal die
zweckmäßigkeit und einmal im entzug
aber beides sind technologisch verfasst
der zweck ist das telos das heißt nicht
formulieren anders natur ist nach der
theologischen anfangs mäßig verfasst das
heißt jeder ecke sie erzielen der die
vögel bauen sich das nest um das alles
so finale konjunktionen finale
subventionen um damit dieses wort um
zeit an dass da als das finale sandvik
angezeigt die vögel bauen sich am
ehesten ihre ganz groß zu ziehen um
ihnen auch zu schützen und das nest ist
zweckmäßig verfasst dass ein sektor hin
so und jetzt könnte man aber auch sagen
aber das ist doch letztendlich eine form
von freiheit oder wenn wir zweckgemäß
handeln nach zecken handeln handeln wir
damals freiheit
kurz gesagt könnte mir doch jetzt zur
ansicht gelangen
freie helfen
nicht nur hier im spiel bei der
vermutlich szene sondern auch hier groß
und zweckmäßigkeit gibt und das ist
diese spannung bezahlt geben viele diese
denken kann habe er nicht direkt der
auffassung sind dass organismen die
diese ebene angesiedelt sind
dass organismen irgendwas mit freiheit
zu tun haben wir dürfen aber diese
freiheit der organismen nicht zu rosen
verstehen wieder die freiheit hier
verstehen dürfen der von nun vorbei die
freiheit der kunst ist immer noch kannte
etwas das mit moral zu moral prinzip das
ist also ich sehe hier gibt es eine
gewisse entnehmen
also wird sind geneigt der kunden zu
vermögen immer schon der theologische
fasten natur dankend zurück es habe also
dass die freiheit zu sprechen dieses
selbstbezüglichkeit das ist nach kant
aber nichts was objektiv der fall ist so
was subjektiv ist ja die reste noch mal
genau also es geht sich noch an die
urteilskraft ich gehe noch mal hier auf
diese grafik zurück also er will damit
sagen kann technologie also zweck wir
sie gefasst hat ist nichts was die natur
betrifft ontologisch also nach kant wer
ist falsch das sagen die natur ist sich
verfasst dieser satz
die natur ist zweck
verfasst dieser satz wäre nach kant so
nicht gültig und müssten gestrichen
das ist man hat die revolution nicht
hier enthaltene geradeheraus und
zweckmäßigkeit ja dass wir würden das
ist die frage ob auch nach heutiger
sicht der nutzer wirklich zweckmäßig
verfährt
sicherlich gibt es sehr erstaunlich gut
angepasste lebensform aber überlegen sie
doch mal wie viele lebensform
ausgestorben sind und die ganzen
nächsten menschen in verwandten homo
erectus neandertal usw und mehr entdeckt
er ständig neue lebensform menschlichen
also jetzt vor kurzem dem alkohol haben
es mitbekommen
der erste bayer dagegen aufrecht so der
ist das ist eine andere menschen hat ist
ausgestorben
das heißt man könnte jetzt da
entgegensetzen die natur die verfährt
nicht nach einem kühlen nach dem ganz
logisch ausgetüftelten plan
und die hat das prinzip von trial and
error verinnerlicht immer wieder gibt es
mutationen spontane mutationen dann wird
mein versuch gestartet
und wenn das nicht funktioniert dann
stört teilt diese lebensform und für uns
die wir jetzt nur auf die erfolgreich
revolutionären produkte schon hat es den
anschein als sei die ganze natur
zweckmäßig verfasst aber es gibt da sehr
viel ausstoß kann würde nicht bestreiten
dass die natur auf uns diesen eindruck
hinterlässt dass sie zwecken jetzt
verfasst sein
nur heute kann mit diesem wort ist ein
problem
er würde es so formulieren wir wir
müssen die natur
als zweckmäßig
beurteilen
und beurteilen wiederum ist nicht
dasselbe dass noch eine weitere
unterscheidung wie erkennen
wenn wir also sagen die natur ist
zweckmäßig gefasst mir ist damit nach
kant keine erkenntnisse gemeint so nur
eine aussage über uns der urteilskraft
wie wir über die natur butter wir müssen
die natur schon erkannt so getan als ob
zweckmäßig fassen das ist einfach das
wichtige was aberkannt wissen muss dass
er nicht mehr sagt die natur ist
zweckmäßig verfassen sondern unsere
urteilskraft ist so verfasst dass sie
die natur als zweckmäßig gut was sind
jetzt die gründe dafür
wissen sie warum die gründe bekannt
dafür geld gemacht dass wir nicht unter
vorgestellt das theologische natur als
etwas zweckmäßigen verfassen
jetzt dazu
dessen
ja ich glaube es geht in die richtige
richtung willkommen da jetzt auch noch
gleich darauf diese frage nachdem die
genese und sofort ganz sagt die natur
ist verkannt es ist letztendlich alles
was nach ursache und wirkung alle
verschärfen müssen so alles war es dem
gesetz von ursache und wirkung
unterliegt einer tourist verkantet sind
alles was den naturgesetzen teilt und
naturgesetz ist er kann nicht dasselbe
wie ein theologisches gesetz naturgesetz
bedeutet nach kant einfach nur das was
alles total ist die causa effizienz
genannt hat auf griechisch natürlich an
das ist lateinisch diese effizienz die
wirklichkeit natur es bekannt alles was
durch diese wirklichkeit beschreibt und
das können wir nach kann tatsächlich
erkennen also wenn wir jetzt sagen
würden die natur ist kausal verfasst
dann wäre das nach kant ein sehr vages
mutter natur ist nach ursachen beruft
hat jetzt kann man natürlich sagen aber
die theologie zweckmäßige erfasst hat
ist doch auch etwas was nach ursachen
fungiert würde kann sagen zur ruhe aber
es ist noch etwas mehr als nur an franco
sondern hier kommt noch so etwas wie die
einzig eine absicht meine intention ins
spiel und die haben wir bei der bloßen
wirklichkeit nicht die können wir uns
ganz mechanisch für sturm das geht dann
nicht auf einen bestimmten zweck hin zu
ist es geht einfach mehr mit den
mechanischen sinnlos aber wirken da
passiert ein ereignis das hat ein
anderes und das verursacht das andere
wegen etwas weg 16
wenn man könnte sagen technologie ist
über determiniert weil wir hier nicht
nur qualität zu nehmen ja noch etwas
darüber hinaus geben ist schon fünf
likes sehr erfreulich dass etwas wie der
reflektierenden urteilskraft zu tun und
nichts mit unserer erkenntnis im stress
deswegen ist theorie nach kant ein
phänomen
etwas was nicht die natur unter logisch
betrifft sind nur uns menschen wie wir
in die natur
zurzeit müssen oder können wir können
nur die natur kennen im strengen sinn
wenn wir sie naturgesetzen nach der
wirklichkeit
wir kommen jetzt gleich noch ein
bisschen genauer drauf zu sprechen und
mein punkt war eben der dass diese
technologie
diese verwandtschaft mit der
rechtmäßigkeit der vernunft da kann
immer dem rad wenn wir es auch nicht
entnehmen sondern zugleich bei der
kurzarbeit kurz bekannt dann auch wenig
wie die geologische fassen
mehr natur hier nur so viel meinte die
natur casale die gesetzmäßige verstandes
gesetzes als wir kommen immer so ein
bisschen wenn wir die natur als
theologische faszien auf die freiheit
des gewissens burger deswegen sagen auch
viele in dieser kritik der urteilskraft
diese treten kritik hätte kann versucht
eine brücke zu schlagen zwischen der
ersten kritik die kredite die natur
verstand entwickelt und der seite merkt
man eben den menschen und die moralität
hat die brücke zwischen naturen freiheit
die hätte kann der trinken kritischen
man kann sich so erklären dass er eben
da auch von einer zick mäßigkeit spricht
die habe nämlich rechtsmäßigkeit ist
aber auch rein bis jetzt genau also
meine youtube zuschauer kann gerne hier
auch mitdiskutiert und mir sagen ob sie
das überzeugend finden jetzt hatten wir
gerade vier und sechs lag sogar fast so
erfolgreich wie das video von haben
okay das ist nur nochmals in der grund-
und jetzt möchte ich neben meiner kurzen
etwas als wiederholung einmal
präsentieren und wir waren die letzten
sitzung darauf zu sprechen kommen ob
jetzt kann der penis des anhängers oder
ein pre formation sein und da hatten wir
diese dinge nicht mehr ganz ausführlich
besprechen kann
deswegen möchte ich jetzt hier nochmal
das mit ihnen als übersicht uns vergehen
wird also zuerkannt wieder aus die
verdeckte technologische und asta wenn
du das technologisch prinzip der zeugen
diese wesen dieser naturwesen ist aber
wir sind angenommen wird
hier ist er nicht anders sein kann wir
können nicht anders als organismen als
theologisch verfasst anzunehmen das
heißt aber nicht dass sie so oder so gut
sein wie es der nicht anders sein kann
so kann man entweder den podcast und
rassismus oder den pre studies musste
ursache ihre wieder rechts weg wer sie
vorne zum grunde also versucht uns das
ganze mal hier ist ein bisschen grafisch
art diagrammen baum diagramm zur
anschauen
also was haben wir von der
unterscheidung zuerst an sie haben ganz
oben hammer besonders nennen das
theologische prinzip der erzeugen
das steht ganzen würde jetzt mal
vorschlagen sie korrigieren dich und mit
augen sind logisches ziel der erzeugung
das ist ganz und jetzt können wir den
pokal finalist oder im praester wenn es
muss darunter unter schauen also ich
kann jetzt praktisch hier gibt es jetzt
als oberstes oberste kategorie aktien
demokratie muss unterscheiden
und den priester bis muss
so jemand erfahrung und der bundestag
bis sie grün doch alles ein bisschen
natürlicher sie können
als joker journalismus und dem preis
sind jetzt müssen sie mir noch sagen
wollte ich da ist doch schöner wenn ich
hinter schwarzen so was sagt jetzt der
ukraine ließ muss was soll ich jetzt
unter occasional ist wie fast der
kommunismus diese ideologie aus
die dfg genau
naja
genauso müsse so verschieden karlsruher
casio ok was heißt es ok ok schon mal
gelegenheit casio das heißt bei
gelegenheit das sagte hier auch selbst
schon sie hier
also frei gelegenheit die gelegenheit
war es eine gelegenheit ist sie gemeint
genau fortpflanzung zurück
also bei dem paarungsakt so sein wird
bei dieser aktion wird praktisch diese
form angewandt auf das was da jetzt
gezeichnet werden es kommt zu sein von
oben das kommt dann aus
hier wäre es jetzt eben von oben je
nachdem wenn eine oberste welt ursache
des wzb gott und göttliche figur
göttlich ursache kenntnis von oben
hinein bei gelegenheit der begattung
wäre würde ihn die sich mischen die
materie sagt er hier die sich mischen
die materie müssen die 2 ws die haben da
würde dann eben plötzlich die organische
bildung mit 1 gegeben
von oben immer bei der ba also man
könnte sagen
besonders sagen
telos reform vor wird bei gelegenheit
als die form damit ist die theologische
form meinte loos zweckform wird bei
gelegenheit von außen in die natur
gebracht
und die die natur könnten sie sich jetzt
so verstehen sie was rein mechanisch
müssen
so könnte man sich dafür verstanden
haben die wesen die diebe sind wenn sie
morgens sind die die funktioniert
einfach nach ihrem prinzip quasi
mechanisch und diese reproduktion
das ist ja der punkt zeugen der
produktion man müsste nur bad eigentlich
diesen organismus auch noch anmelden bei
regeneration
die kann mit regeln zum erklären ohne
cdu geht also dieser okkasion alles muss
dürfte nicht nur bei gelegenheit der
fortpflanzen kann auch gelegenheit bei
gelegenheit der reproduktion müsste die
ratten spielen können also dass die
natur die vielleicht nur mechanisch
gedachte die wird immer bei gelegen hat
wenn sich das wesen mit einem angespart
um zu produzieren
dann kommt wird sich die vom niederrhein
aus aber es liegt diesen dingen nicht so
zugrunde dass es von ihnen selbst aus
weitergeht ist der opfer zivilisten
ok und davon muss man jetzt hier
[Musik]
nach dem ersten wechsel nach dem zweiten
das jetzt hier das nach dem zweiten
würde sie in die anfänglichen produkte
dieser ihre wesen hat
die anlage gebracht haben vermittelt der
ein organisches lesen seinesgleichen
erfüllt und die des pcs sich
selbstständig hält ja wie soll man das
was soll ich denn da unterschreiben
[Musik]
selbstständigen selbstständig erhalten
bevor
also ich sag innere anlage
sechs der form nicht voll aus das ist
der gegensatz von pausen kommt es beim
zuschauer ist noch nicht ganz soweit
alles okay zu sein
das ist die grundlage kann zeigt jetzt
die sozialismus den kampf vergessen das
ist ein haltbares gegenhalten haben die
idee warum ist der unhaltbar im kasten
verspricht dagegen
was ist der absolut ja
genau ich muss also demnach vielmehr
noch anliegen um eben ja er muss
vielmehr erleben was ich eigentlich gar
nicht müsste wenn ich das team musste
etwas metaphysisches etwas außerhalb der
motorrad nehmen und das ist immer ein
bisschen schwierig und vor allem ich
muss immer wieder annehmen und nicht
immer nicht eben nur bei einer gelegen
nicht eben als etwas zu grunde die
polizei so und jetzt immer weiter und
jetzt sagte er folgendes der priester
wird es muss also dass auf der rechten
seite hier impressionismus kann wiederum
auf zwei verfahren und beraten
betrachtet nämlich ein jedes von seinem
gleichen gezeugt organische ist entweder
als das juckt oder als das produkt es
ist das system der zeugung der als
bloßer ägypter heißt das der
individuellen reformation also sagen wir
mal das müssen wir hier weiter sie
korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch lag das
kann man sich hier wieder so zeugen
machen und das eine von dem jetzt
spricht ist dass die evolutionstheorie
und die werde durch individuelle pre
formation aus gezeigt
die präsentation
und zwar als also eine zeugung als wir
müssen erklären was ein idiot ist
so gut und was kannst du davon ab von
der evolutionstheorie nach diesem zitat
das entsorgen als produkte wird das
system tps es gibt da zu beginn des
ergebnisses
das wäre die zeugung als produkte
produkte sagte noch was
ja
genau generische
gibt es sonst noch weitere bestimmt wie
können sie es genau verstehen ganzen
sagte diesen gemäß würde man die
athleten steht er wieder in die welt
reformation der informationstheorie
also man könnte es auch in volution
dem sind so gegensätze volution stil
und jetzt ist das noch ein bisschen
genauer verständlich machen fünf
zuschauer
kann man schon ein bisschen weiter
wissen sie was eine einigung ist
so könnte man sagen
ja so kenianischen begriff der ist gar
nicht so klar ich habe mal im kanton
nachgeschaut bei den komplex kommen das
internet finden steht entfallen also ein
edler entfaltung an den falten wie lese
jetzt einfach mal weiter
und das noch ein bisschen klang die
verrichtete evolutionstheorie welche
jedes individuum von der bild und dem
kraft der natur aus nehmen um es
wunderbar aus der hand des schöpfers
kommen zu lassen
das geht jetzt ja eigentlich fast die
operation ist aber dass ich dasselbe
wollten ist also doch nicht wagen
dieses das individuum nach der hypothese
des organismus geschehen zu lassen so
dass die begattung eine bloße formalität
wäre unter der eine oberste verständige
welt unser angeschlossen hätte jedes mal
eine fruchtbare hans bilden und die
mutter der motor nur die auswechselung
und ernährung derselben zu erlassen sie
erklärten sich für die pre formation
gleich als wenn es nicht einerlei wäre
übernatürlichen reise im anfang oder im
vorlauf der welt der gleichen form
entstehen zu lassen und nicht vielmehr
eine große menge übernatürliche
anstalten durch gelegentliche schöpfen
erspart wurde mich erforderlich wäre
damit ihren anfang der welt gebildet die
ngo die lange zeit hindurch bis zu
seiner entwicklung nicht von der
zerstörung nicht von den zerstörungen
kräften der fit und sich unverletzt
erhielt im gleichen eine unermesslich
größere zahl solcher vor gewesen als
jemals entwickelt für den zu rücken
mit ihm geben soviel schöpfen dadurch
benötigen
das gemacht wird was ist jetzt der
unterschied zwischen den
professionalismus und der nutzung
si
vielleicht sagen leute was mich
alle so
er sagt die revolutionsbewegung jedes in
bildung von der bilder kraft aus nehmen
aber sie wollten nicht nur kasoulis
vertreten dass eben diese formung diese
technologische form von außen kommt und
wartet das muttertier dann nur noch das
ganze aus entwickeln müsse das heißt die
form muss schon einen gewissen
reformation heißt es liegt die
vormenschen zuvorzukommen und es kommt
nicht hinaus
gelesen das nächste tat er meint sie
die vertreter der evolutionstheorie sie
wollten doch weg ist etwas jährige natur
überlassen um nicht gar um völlige
physik zu geraten
die aller natur erklärung entbehren kann
hyper physik bedeutet eine physik über
der physik und metaphysik eigentlich ne
super bedeutet über er könnte auch
metaphysiker haben gesagt da habe ich
nicht wissen sie warum kann die nicht
mit musik setzen nur über füssen
weil er den begriff der mit der musik
und des wort metaphysik mussten gebaut
muss sagen in einem anderen kontext
gebraucht hat zb grundlegung zur
metaphysik der sitten oder metaphysik
der sitten
also mit flüssiges verkannt ein wort das
sehr positiv wieder geprägt wird von ihm
etwas was gerade nicht im schlechten
sinne über natürlich ist so etwas
durchaus konkret werden kann zum
beispiel unser feind da ist mit der sie
ganz zu tun möchte eine neue bestimmung
der mitte vor dem ich möchte mich nicht
abschaffen was er hingegen abschaffen
möchte ist eine hyper physik also eine
physik die spekulativ ist und gar nichts
mehr mit natur ursächlichkeit zu tun hat
sondern mit journalistischen ganzen
täten die letztendlich von einer
übernatürlichen usa stammt das möchte
ich nicht und das ist für kann nicht mit
musik so ein hübsches ok und selbst
emotions theoretikern erkannt wollten
keine völlige sie kabel sich jeder
sondern auch fest an ihrer hyper physik
selbst da sie an miss geboten die man
doch unmöglich 40 natur halten kann an
dem wunder als würdige 10 möglichkeit
fanden
sollte sie aber auch nur darauf gezielt
sein dass
mika einmal daran als einer zwecklos
unzweckmäßigkeit an stunden den
anschluss nehmen und niederschlagen die
wunde führen sind arbeiten zeugen
gefasst hatte konnten sich
schlechterdings nicht mit der system der
pre formation hineinpassen ja sonst
müsste man überlegen wie das von dieser
über physischen qualität kommt wenn sich
ein wesen nicht so entwickelt die es mal
nicht so mussten dem samen der
männlichen stück für dem es übrigens
nichts als die mechanische eigenschaften
zu ersten chancen dass im jute dienen
zugestanden hatten
doch nach oben einen zweckmäßig bilden
die kraft zu gestehen
wenn es jedoch in ansehung des ganzen
produkt eine erzeugung von zwei
geschöpfen derselben gattin keinen von
beiden einräumen wollten sie der gute
mann hat er häufig versucht die zeugung
ganz nach mechanischen muster sind ihre
mechanische musste wäre reine natur ist
ursache wirkung
und jetzt stellen uns die frage wo kommt
jetzt hier seine zweckmäßig bilden die
kraft diese bildungslücke wie kommt der
jetzt ist er bei man und samen und
eizelle gelegen sollte man heute sagen
weder das alles andere sind nur wenn sie
das sagen bekommen sie dann bildet sich
dass er für sich genommen sind die sind
wäre es nicht versteht was wenn man
dagegen an den verteidiger der apps ist
den großen vorzug der in ansehung der
erfahrungs grunde zu beweisen eine
theorie vor den erstern hat als vor dem
der
evolutionstheorie gleich nicht kennt so
wird die vernunft doch schon zum voraus
dass seine erklärungsarbeit mit
vorzüglicher kunst eingenommen sein weil
sie die natur der dinge welche man
ursprünglich nur nach der qualität der
säcke sich als möglich vorstellt hat
doch wenigstens was die fortan zu
betrifft als selbst hervorbringt nicht
bloß als entwickeln betrachtet und so
doch mit dem kleinstmöglichen aufwand
das übernatürliche alles folgende von
erst anfange an der natruper lässt ohne
aber über die ersten anfang an denen die
physik überhaupt scheitern
das mag es mit einer kette der ursachen
versuchen mit welcher sowohl etwas
stimmt vielleicht gesetz unterscheidet
klar zwischen reduktionszielen und wie
er sagt er hier also die ip gen es ist
eine produktive produktives verständnis
natur hervorbringen und die
evolutionstheorie ist bloß entwickelt
entwickeln
wie kann man sich das vorstellt muss
entwickeln wo es entwickelt bedeutet die
form ginczek muss selbst noch nicht
darin enthalten sind der zweck kommt
vielleicht woanders vielleicht von außen
jedenfalls hat die natur nur hier diese
eigenschaft den zweck zu entwickeln aber
nicht dem zweck zu setzen dass also eine
schwächere tiere die evolutionstheorie
ist eine schwäche bettchen
was jetzt technologische die mit
betrifft oder fitness betrifft jemanden
auf der ebene der urteilskraft die
mischung objektive erkenntnis während
die mpg de system wie die kranken zu
bevorzugen
während die eben der natur selbst
elf als hervorbringt einzig unterstehen
doch wenigstens fortan selbst
hervorbringt nicht bloß das ist bekannt
überzeugt ein natur beurteilung die
selbst die ganz aus sich selbst heraus
und die zecke nicht nur vorgesetzt
bekommt von mobbing und es dann nur noch
ein blick rosig
das heißt unser verständnis von
evolutionstheorie ist eine eher dass das
kann die revolution geben nur das
entwickeln eines an der ausfahrt er
stehe zu diesen kann der ausfall und ich
dieses produktive hervorbringen dieses
wirklich zeugen das neue neue generieren
als der bildung streep ist ganz klar wer
hier ewig verstanden wie bei uns müssen
uns einfach mal fragen wie das vorher da
war sagt er was woher diese form kommt
es wird sich noch bei hertha bsc war der
und das so scheint es ihr auch zu sein
als diese form halten bei hertha doch
ziel des lichtes und schoss fast von
außen zu kommen die form läuft auf den
menschen hinaus aber der menschen hier
um hat das eine theologische und
metaphysische hyper füße schon erkannt
jetzt die mission und das deutet darauf
hin dass es von außen der reformation
und jetzt kommt's zum abschluss dieser
unserer theorie in bezug auf blumenbach
noch er sagt kann sagt finanzierung
dieser theorie dfb geht es hat niemand
mehr beweise sehen als auch zur gründung
der echten prinzipien ihrer anbindung
zum teil durch die beschränkung eines zu
vermessenen gebrauchs derselben
geleistet als herr hofrat umbach und
organisierter materie hebt der alles
physische alle physische erklärungs art
dieser bildung an
wenn das wohl materie sich nach
mechanischen gesetz ursprünglich selbst
gebildet habe
das aus der natur des leblosen leben
habe entsprechen und materien die form
einer sich selbst erhaltenden
zweckmäßigkeit sich von selbst habe
fügen können erklärt damit recht für
vernunft niedrig und friedrich meint das
ist ja ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass
es unsere vernunft widerspricht aber
unserem urteil der stich lässt aber
zugleich er lässt aber zugleich den
kommunismus unter diesem uns
unerforschten prinzip nämlich die
rechtmäßigkeit eine ursprünglich
organisation ein unbestimmbaren zugleich
doch auch unverkennbar
wozu das vermögen der materie zu
unterschiede von der allgemein ball
wohnende mechanischen bildungsgrad und
schauen sie jetzt kommt ihr bildungs
kraft und musste von ihrem in einem
organisierten körper ein gleichsam unter
der höheren leitungen an weise der
ersten steht der bildung streep genannt
also der sommer lässt aber zugleich
natürlich wissen
100 stück barren anteil
und es gibt eine mechanische bremskraft
die gehört der materie an oder
unterscheidet wohnbach erkannt eine
organische körper der einbildung das
wollen wir uns auch noch mal hier ein
bisschen vergehen wird also zeugen als
bloße entfaltungen entfaltung der form
klar woher
woher kommt ihr vor das ist unklar
und die geldes ist die produktion
hervorbringen
hervorbringen der vorm haus sicher aus
und das ist so eine form von autonomie
habe ich schreibt in einem verstrichen
autonomie markant an ihm was ist was mit
freiheit guten rat
das habe ich ihr nicht zu hoch bewerten
ist diese liegt in einem youtube
zuschauern dann richtig das kann man
hier zwischen oder rosa wortgleich
selbsthilfe der erzeugung ja alles hängt
damit die frage ist woher kommt die form
eines neuen organ ist willkommen
[Musik]
wo er einen sehr interessanten gedanken
eingebracht hat
wir fahren
die animationen dass die welt abläuft
und anna zu besetzen
aber warum am ende das ergebnis anders
ausschauen kann bis die nation gesetze
erwarten massen davon abhängt dass der
ablauf und natur selbst wenn so
ungeheuer viele querschüssen von
woanders her kommen
das ergebnis anders agieren kann mich
davon ab wenn ich einen gedanken dabei
spreche sein dass die evolution szene
oder die noch die genese dieses phänomen
erklärt dass die evolutionstheorie zu
aktionen sie verstanden haben dass die
einer der gründe und
einreisebestimmungen für das ergebnis
der evolution zunächst eine mutation und
dann anschließend lektion kommunikation
als rechtmäßiger weise sei nicht die
mutation unter irgendeinem irrtum
erzeugt worden ist der mit dem
gegenstand überhaupt nichts zu tun
romy zu irgendeinem ein feind ihres
obenauf eingeflogen ist und eine meile
auf biologischen eigenschaften eines ja
also ich schreibe wie graf immerhin weil
sie auf dem ozean sind wenn sie jetzt
von der evolutionstheorie sprechen dann
meinen sie nach country dance revolution
das ist der moderne begriff und er habe
sehr schade diesem video was ich
verlinkt haben und rechts davon
gesprochen dass wir gar nicht reden und
von einem determinismus sprechen können
weil es wie sie richtig sagen nachlässt
so viele ungenauigkeiten füße gibt und
letztendlich einfach die natur
nach löschen gar nicht strikt
determiniert ist er hat alles schon
gesagt kein physiker würde heutzutage
behaupten dass die natur strikte termin
ist ist hat er auf ein hoch folgt der
falkenburg von mit dem titel mythos der
tennis und die physik die ja dafür
zuständig ist dieser bleiben gibt es gar
können wir gar nicht experimentell
nachweisen
allerdings kann natürlich die für die
philosophie sagen und so verläuft
derzeit auf filme des denkens die
gebietet uns das alles ein us besatzung
zu recht im grunde von letzten endes
andernfalls müsste es ereignisse geben
die gar keinen grund haben unterstützt
und das scheint auch in unserer 15
entsprechen dann sehen sie die für sechs
sagt völlig offen und experimentell
termins nicht begründen und erwartet
philosophie sagte vernunft sagt uns
etwas anderes die
damit nicht zufrieden diese also aus
musikalischer sicht ist der
determinismus nicht so ein großes
problem wie für die philosophie die eben
eher so ein 5 konzept hier
dahinter stehe abhängig und mit k4 punkt
zurück kommen jetzt kann man sich ja
nicht verhängt diese diese in der termin
ist aus dieser physikalischen
determinismus sind die evolutionstheorie
zu sagen könnte man diesen determinismus
auf die mutation und selektion beziehen
das problem als ein pc ist dass man hier
eben zwei verschiedene disziplinen
miteinander in verbindung bringen muss
nämlich die evolutionstheorie die auf
einer biologischen ebene durch eine
chemisch mechanischen ebene gelegen ist
und die physikalischen aus einer atomar
noch zur atomaren wie sie gelagert ist
und man kann eben gar nicht schwer
auf basis von atomaren verhältnissen
oder noch kleinen verhältnissen die lohn
geschäft phänomen erklären
ganz schwierig bei der photosynthese
geht es ein bisschen
das geht solange ganz kleines bisschen
geht es nämlich nicht falscher vermögen
aber erklären sie mal die funktionsweise
eines eines mangels eines gehirns eines
regenwurms mit physikalischen methoden
oder erklären sie uns unsere gedanken
wie unsere qualität objektiven eindrücke
kauf nehmen für sie kommt auf der
physikalischen ebene des geht kann
momentan nicht
die frage ist ob es überhaupt geht
bewiesen button das müsste mir nehmen
überlegen wie diese zweiten biologie und
physik wie die in der evolutionstheorie
zusammengebracht somit für die tafel
gewischt und wir kommen auf unser thema
der heutigen eigentlichen sitzung zurück
nämlich kommen wir jetzt
die energie wieder zu sprechen
diesmal auf die kritik der praktischen
förderkredite praktische vernunft hat
kann vor der kritik der urteilskraft
geschrieben und ich bringe noch mal in
china aber erst noch die leitfragen 20
uhr 1 kommentar der heutigen sitzung
also welche rolle spielen trieb finden
kann es moralisch so viel wie verhalten
sich die triebfedern hier den betrieb
der natur
wir hängen trieb werden und freiheit
miteinander zusammen
jetzt bekommen wir plötzlich neu begriff
ja nochmal ganz rückblickend vielleicht
muss ich doch noch einmal zurückgehen
schauen wir noch das letzte zitat
hiervon kann der herr sprache einmal von
der mechanischen bindungskraft und im
bildungs trieb haben sie es mechanisch
bindungskraft hier und bildung streep
hier und es scheint mir ganz wichtig zu
sein das sollten wir noch mal fest heben
thomas kraft
und die zahl dagegen noch den bildungs
trieb
was müsste ich dann da vorschalten nicht
mechanisch sondern ja oder richtig oder
ja das ist auch richtig
ich würde sagen oder gar nicht aber es
ist also organe oder zweckmäßiger wurde
theologische bildung streep
hier könnt ihr jetzt unterschreiben
mechanische das könnte ich noch
unterschreiben
ja ja genau diese causa infiziert das
ist die kamera in 14
das hier ist die causa finales so also
kann sagt okay wir müssen kraft von
trieb unterscheiden das schon mal etwas
sagen also kraft ist eine physikalische
wenn wir jetzt hier nochmal
unterscheidung machen dann ist das ihr
die physik für sie kannte von craft
wissen sie noch die moderne physik
wasserköpfe sie kennt die gravitations
los
elektromagnetische kraft
ja
genauer starke wissen sie auch noch wo
die starken schwachen kräfte fokus
ja
ich glaube ich nämlich nicht falsch ist
die schwache die starke bei geologischen
verhältnissen zur chemischen van der
waals kräfte kennen sie die van der wals
kraft aus dem chemieunterricht van der
wals kraft ist glaube ich nicht
starke wo man eigentlich denken würde
eine schwache bitte auch korrigieren auf
youtube für zwei tage und die schwache
könnte ist glaube ich etwas was ihr das
universum betrieb für größere dimension
aber sie könnte man abschied für uns ist
hier wichtig eigentlich nur eigentlich
ja in unserem unserem kosmos was uns
betrifft es halt ist dann wenn ich jetzt
hier meinen stift loslassen fällt nach
unten das ist die gravitationskraft ja
und wenn ich leben
strom fließen lasse entsteht in der
griff magnetisches feld und wird oder
wenn ich zum beispiel magnet habe dann
zieht der reisen an was richtig gepolt
ist merkt sie dass das sind
elektromagnetische kräfte
die sind für uns im alter
ok kann spricht ja einfach
einbildungskraft und es entscheiden dies
erkannt und das hier wäre jetzt endlich
die biologie eigentlich oder vielleicht
auch die ökologie und systemisch
betrachtet können wir erkennen
nur hier und hier können wir nur brutal
das ist eine interessante erkenntnis
strengen sinne gibt es nur hier bei der
physik sollen sagen die zusammenfassung
der kritik der urteilskraft
das ist eine tiefe ok genau alles gab
dann immer weiter und kam jetzt gesagt
unsere thema der heutigen sätzen zu
sprechen
eben wie verhalten sich triebfeder und
kann es noch ein philosophie auf die
ersten blick könnte es doch den anschein
haben das triebfedern etwas mechanisches
sind welcher dimension würden sie jetzt
den begriff triebfeder zuordnen die
bildungsträger der erklärt bildungs
kraft triebfeder
als triebfeder höher es würden sich dazu
erst zeigen
ja als ich würde sogar anderen melden
ich würde es als ich hätte jetzt
intuitiv aber jeder hat andere
stationiert intuitiv gesagt triebfeder
ist in die bindungskraft ja ok sie haben
recht jahr richtig habe ich gar nicht
gesehen ein guter punkt genau also
richtig von dem das vom board hier haben
wollte würde man gleich hier auf das
organische kommen trieb habe eine gute
bemerkung trieb trieb deutet darauf hin
dass es organisches hat weil sonst würde
er von kraft sprechen triebe sind immer
organisch bedingt die mechanische natur
hat kein trieb höchsten sein antrieb ein
antrieb ein motor und die feder hingegen
würde ich jetzt erst dieser bildungs
kraft ziehen warum
was könnte der grund sein
ja
ja genau triebfeder wo kommen die
triebfeder vor
genau oder zum beispiel können keine
fehler auch kraft speicher nur
angenommen
zum beispiel gut unruhe die dann
angetrieben wird ja also ich ziehe ich
wenn ich immer so mechanisch aufziehen
da natürlich die fehelr 1 gibt es die
feder konstante kann ich mit kräften
hatten kraft wissen kraft wieder mit
news kann es im westen
so können am newtonmeter sie können es
gibt ja solche newtonmeter da hängen sie
an gewicht an seinem fehler und je
nachdem wie weit sie ausgelegt wird ich
kann kräfte erzielen dem ich einen
fehler ziehe aber auch nicht dass es am
druck ist genau dasselbe
und ich kann aber wenn ich jetzt eine
newtonmeter habe dann kann ich an seine
federn an gewicht hängen und je nachdem
wie das runterzieht es zu mir kraft gibt
es natürlich die gravitationskraft und
auf den ersten blick legt der begriff
triebfeder tatsächliche mechanisches
modell nämlich so was von einem betrieb
nur hat mit heraufziehen
das sind mechanische kräfte tun und
jetzt kann man sich verhalten streep
jetzt hier dann eine metapher na ja das
ganze gebilde hier triebfeder ist nach
kann schon metapher wahrheit kontext
banken wir jetzt in die betrieb werde
nicht mehr im kontext der physik nicht
im kontext der physik nicht im kontext
der biologie ökologie sondern im kontext
ja genau
mal philosophie
und hier geht es also hier das war
praktisch ursache wirkung des wagner und
jetzt können wir schauen was wir hier
zeigen
hier haben wir es mit wissen sie doch
dass schema was kann da entwickelt hatte
hier etwas sage das ganz toll hier also
auf dieser ebene müssen sie bleiben dass
die moral von also bis die ebene die
spalte die zeitung nicht ja genau
vernünftig diese zahlen müssen sie
betreffen beginn an diese zeit
das heißt hier geht es um im wald was es
heißt sie geht es letztendlich um den
kurs ein print senken und zwar wirklich
auch um den willen hier geht es
letztendlich um wollen oder handeln ja
ok also wohl und handeln hat das ist
hier und jetzt haben wir hier eigentlich
alles wieder schönen zimmer
untergebracht werden triebfeder hat er
nie was von beidem trieb von organischen
und feder von mechanischen erste
endzweck also absoluter cnc ist die
moralität dann sehen sie natürlich
wieder bei herde es war auch der entzug
gewesen
die momente der infekte form es gibt wie
es nicht
und jetzt mal schauen
neben es nach den leidvollen die wir
haben wie sich jetzt die triebfedern
betrieben erkannte auch noch sowas
getriebe
also es stimmt nicht hundertprozentig er
spielt von bildungs kraft der schmeckt
auch noch manchmal vertrieben
die vertriebe und triebe sind so ein
bisschen im system von kant mich ganz
klar verortet eigentlich betriebe
verstanden als gefühle als neigungen
etwas was aus dem naturstoff also hier
muss ich die natur entstanden natur und
zwar allen die nicht beliebt
ganz komisch wir sind auf lebewesen nur
lebewesen abend neigungen und das hier
ist die belebte natur als er trieb der
liegt zwischen diesen beiden bereichen
getrieben alles kam mir nicht ganz genau
ein jahr und wir hängen triebfeder und
freiheit mit einer gesamtleistung von
tieren und kurz ein bisschen stellt
diese frage doch noch ein bisschen zeit
durch sagt mir hier fragen hand und
schluss gibt offensichtlich allen
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer dann dann
würde ich sagen lesen man bloß nicht die
fehler eigentlich nicht mal ein ja wenn
dem so ist ist die letzte zeit
jetzt richtig als moralphilosophie die
krank so nicht das verstehe und das ist
der privaten kapitals der brandung in
der form erster jähriges lieber im ural
sind so viel kann doch gewissermaßen nur
einmal ein beurteilen der filter über
den triebe und ingrid feder sein und
bestimmen diesen unterlief dürfen wir es
aus moral gesiegt folge oder nicht ja
aber die existenz der feder ist douglas
unabhängigen warum warten ja sehr
berechtigte frage haben also man könnte
denken okay die triebfedern kommen von
der natur oder von wo auch immer sie
kommen von hausen und wie beurteilen sie
nun aber es ist tatsächlich so dass kann
zeigt wir haben eine eigene triebfeder
die aus der vernunft stammt und zwar
eine moralische triebfeder nicht von der
natur gegeben ist ist das dann noch
nicht der richtige reise als triebfeder
bezahlen so das ist eine berechtigte
frage und ich glaube nicht aber kann
nennt siegfried werden wir müssen müssen
uns überlegen warum er das tut
ich schreibe hier auch noch hierhin nach
hirschau wiener vernunft verstand und
urteils kasse
jetzt hatten sich während ihres teams
das würde sagen was darüber ist dann
scheint sich aber zu dem schluss dass
eine belohnung nachtragshaushalt einiges
voraus
[Musik]
gegen eine demokratisch ist aus achtung
vor dem gesetz völlig normal
deswegen ist der selbst weniger
wahrscheinlich
ja genau wir uns auf die kurvenlage die
leute alles ist bis jetzt ein neues
gesetz herr beide recht also das ist
richtig kann sagt also man müsste es
vielleicht so fangen den krieg rede ist
jetzt verkannt die moralischen sicht
eigentlich sowie motivation motiv werden
beweggrund
das problem ist nehmen wir über
motivation reden reden wir immer schon
mechanistisch triebfeder ganz klar
mechanisch beweggrund dem haus motiv
mobile bewegen ist ein physikalischer
begriff aristoteles die bewegung ist im
tal der physik nicht der moral funktion
das heißt wir haben irgendwie nur
begriffe die aus dem bereich der physik
also mechanistische metapher die wir
übertragen das bereich dem rad feld in
dem ein wort ein oder am griff er sofort
was nicht mechanistisch ist das aber
trotzdem aber dass trotzdem unsere
seelenzustände oder uns motivation
bezeichnen kann also an keinem tabu sein
da hätte man eben wieder den trieb so
ein bisschen
wir hatten hier gesehen betrieb steht
kommt eben von außen hier in ihrem
betrieb ist hier etwas was ihm so latent
biologisch gut biologisch oder streep
hat so ein bisschen was metaphorisches
wenn man das dann
man könne natürlich sagen vielleicht
meinen sie so ich bin eben jetzt ich
habe ein trieb nach schokolade gut dann
klar würde ist das nicht trotzdem eine
metapher oder bin ich will man könnte in
billens nickel mein wille war der wille
bestimmte intention
das ist sowas internationalität wille er
will jetzt ganz wichtig und der wille
ist natürlich was was den islam nicht
mit der vorsprung wille ist will ich
weiß nicht was ich in angst jetzt muss
man nur fragen was kann mit dem willen
alles tun und keine will bestimmen
bestimmte sie sich unbedingt ist
bestimmte metaphern zu sein
bestimmendes neutral oder alles möglich
bestimmen den willen motivieren das
immer wieder mit der wurfbereich werden
bilden
da haben wir jetzt bildung hat diese
zwei seiten da bin ich mir ganz sicher
was ursprünglicher ist bildung bildung
hat was gestalterisches will und etwas
was wo die form ein
was ein wirklicher bilden und dann bin
ich nicht mehr so sehen
mit der frischen getränken aber das ist
ein ganz ganz zentrales thema
habe ich immer sehr okay dann lesen
einfach mal weiter aus der kritik der
praktischen vernunft
er sagt das wesentlich alles sittlichen
werts der handlung kommt darauf an dass
das moralische gesetz sittengesetz und
mit bade im film bestimmen jetzt aber
wieder gestimmt
das passt nicht mit geschieht die wsr
stimmen zwar gemäß dem omanischen
besitzen aber nur vermittels eines
gefühls welche altes koch sei das
vorausgesetzt werden mussten mit jenes
nämlich das moralische gesetz ein
hinreichend der bestimmung des südens
werde mit ihm nicht um des gesetzes
fehle so wird die handlung zwar
legalität aber nicht moralität taten
wenn er unter triebfeder theater alimi
das ist einfach magisch an die mail
systeme der subjektive bestimmung des
und des willens eines wesens gestanden
der sinn von uns nicht schonvermögen
seine natur dem objektiven gesetze
notwendig gemäss ist sondern erst ich
daraus folgt dass man dem göttlichen
willen gar kein trieb für den beilegen
können
triebfeder des menschlichen willens aber
und das von jedem schaffen künftigen
wesen niemals etwas anders als das
moralische gesetz sein können
mithin der objektiven bestimmung grund
jederzeit und ganz allein zugleich der
subjektiv hinreichende bestimmte
handlung sein müsse wenn diese nicht los
dem buchstaben des gesetzes ohne im
geist des lebens enthalten erfüllt oder
es ist gar nicht lange hat langer satz
als der satz geht von hier noch alles zu
jeder satz von
nachdem hier ist darunter das ist schon
eine ganz ordentliche strecke ist die
durststrecke war als ja schon richtig
vorhin gesagt geht es hier was ist hier
soll die die rahmenbedingungen
worum geht es geht um die bestimmung des
wählers haben es geht um bestimmungen
gründe
das gibt dem hinreichende stimmen und
dessen bestimmung gründe die dazu führen
dass der wille zu einer handlung kommt
das ist damit gemeint also es gibt zwar
möglichkeiten es gibt den bestimmungen
durch ein gefühl
oder durch das romanische bis jetzt erst
das ist der punkt jetzt mache ich dieses
schöne wurde nicht so schön wie auch
immer erst einmal weg und versuchen wir
das hier so ein bisschen übersichtlicher
gestalten das kann hier sagt also es
gibt bestimmen des willens so heißt du
willst meine dissertation so heißt sie
nach unten video und linke kritisiert
prozent rabatt
so stellen wir zehn schon zu erkennen
das mag stimmen dass sie bekommen die
alle kostenlos als pdf bestimmung des
willens
also einmal nur durch ein gefühl
nach oben rechts und klein durch ein
gefühl oder durch das sit ins und zwar
muss man dazu sagen
durch das sieht ein gesetz unmittelbar
und diese bestimmung diese man sich das
vorstellen diese zwei faktoren haben
einfluss auf die bestimmende entwicklung
soll diese pfeile jetzt verdeutlichen
und dann entsteht daraus aus der
bestimmung des wilson steht aus
in beiden fällen entsteht eine handlung
die frage ist natürlich dann wie sie
richtig sagen welchen sittlichen werte
hat aber jedenfalls beide malen steht in
hand bzw
sie haben eigentlich recht wir müssen
jetzt eigentlich anders machen
ich mache das noch ein bisschen anders
ich verstehe dass dieser diese tolle
vater hier dieses virtuelle dieser
virtuellen trafen schiebt das x bis
hinter und ich nehme mal dass sie doch
einmal weg das gefällt mir nicht nur auf
die palme ich mal weg ein weil ich was
anderes ist ein anderes machen sie habe
ich das grab gebracht nation bestimmung
des willens so wir können einmal so
machen es einmal durch ein gefühl einmal
durch das sittengesetz mit bauen wenn
der wille da setzt er wieder wenn der
jetzt durch ein gefühl stück wird dann
ist die handlung nur naja zumindest
nicht moralisch heißt es legal unter
umständen wenn sie aber durch das
sittengesetz unmittelbar bestimmt wird
dann ist die handlung der wille der
stiftung ist hier geboren
was ist damit gemeint was gibt es für
gefühlen wie durch welches gefühl könnte
ein wille bestimmt werden noch einmal
mutig zu schauen
was die gefühle können und zum bestimmen
was können motive bestimmung ist könnte
man sagen motivation
also selbst liebe
hast du
ja zb an ist ist auch noch was zum
beispiel könnte ich angst haben vor
strafe also ich könnte in dem sieben
gesetz gemäß handeln aber nicht aus
pflicht also pflichtgemäß wäre es auch
pflicht das auslöschen
ich könnte zum beispiel angst vor strafe
haben weil ich angst vor strafe habe
handle ich dem 7 6 gemäß dann ist aber
die bestimmung des willens nicht
unmittelbar durch das gesetz erfolgt so
eben nur mittelbar weil sich darauf das
gefühl der angst dazwischen geschoben
hat das heißt die handlung ist ja nur
legal aber nicht moralisch und stießen
gleich pflichtgemäß
und das ist auch pflicht mehr kann das
pflicht
nicht genehm ist das ist bloss legalität
im gesetz gemäß aber was man eigentlich
grund war reduzierten gesetz gemäß zu
handlungen zb nicht zu lügen hat dass
der kategorische imperativ befiehlt
niemals zurück
jetzt bin ich in der situation in der
ich mögen könnte bürger aber nicht
dann würde kann deswegen weil ich lüge
nicht gleich sagen ministranten
moralisch so wird immer fragen was und
ein grund dafür dass du nicht gelungen
hast würde ich jetzt sage ja ich hatte
angst dass die lüge auffliegen könnte
später weil die kanzlei war die handlung
nicht moralisch im strengen sinn dort
nur pflichtgemäß was ist jetzt aber ein
gefühl was eben uns den willen durch das
gesetz unmittelbar bestimmen ist
lauf läuft dieses kapitels aus das ist
die achterbahn stiftung
er sah auch einen aufsatz geschrieben
kürzlich den verlegten der beschreibung
können sich unterlagen auf englisch und
dieses achtungs gefühl sagt er ganz
seltsame dinge gesagt es ein vernunft
gewölbtes gefühl als ein gefühl eine
triebfeder die aus der vernunft staub
aus den eintrag zukunft sowas kann
natürlich bestreiten
ist das wirklich kippen
und das ist noch kann die einzige
triebfeder das einzige gefühl das der
einzige materiale bestimmungsort einzige
motivationsgrund gehe auch ziemlich also
wirklich warm willens mäßig ohne diesen
wärme hat der nach kein moralisches
sagte ach du bist ein gefühl
okay das ist also die unterscheidung
zwischen normalität und legalität ist
ganze zeit habe die zuschauer etwas
träge wie sonst im kreis sind da ist das
wochenende dafür sind wir hier aktiv ja
wenn ihr das wirklich verstehen
nur manchen emotionen und nicht alle
nämlich nicht beachtung
wir kommen jetzt noch ein bisschen drauf
hat das ist eigentlich genau dasselbe
also das wesentlich als es gibt ein
gefühl das geht das gewollt das ist gut
das ist die achte aber alle anderen
gefühlen
das heißt nicht dass kann alle anderen
flüge ausschließen möchte aber er sagt
die dürfe nicht der primäre bestimmung
kommt dass wir uns zum beispiel erkannt
wenn ich einem freund helfen aus
freundschaft aus liebe weil ich einen
freund gerne haben oder die partnerin
ein partner liebe dann ist es kein
moralischer bestimmungsbuch das ist
nicht moralische stütze aus liebe zur
handlung noch drastischer aus mitleid zu
handeln würden sie doch bestimmt alles
sagen wer das sagen dass aus mitleid an
die moralisch ist nicht mit dem wagen
deutlicher werden nicht gesehen wie man
für uns
also wer glaubt von ihnen dass das
mitleid mit gefühl ein renommee
moralisches motiv ist eine genuine
courage triebfeder die hier den wir dann
eben somit war natürlich bestimmen lässt
zur pflicht handlung als zu diesem guten
stimme ich bloß illegalität ist moral
und ich glaube das mitleid einen
wirklichen moralische treffens aus ihrer
sicht muss das machen
okay das hatte ich nämlich darf ich
werde auch muss eigentlich gegen tief
jetzt gemeinsam es ist sowas ja aber
selbst da sein kann nein
mitleid ist nicht unser primäres
moralisches gefühl was sind seine könnte
haben sie eine idee warum ist nach kann
zum beispiel liebe keine geeignete moral
vertrieb für und auch mitleid mit ja
genau liebe zum beispiel ist immer recht
subjektiven hat den angeblich der wand
nicht mitleid hinaus oder als er würde
zu sein dass solche moralischen gefühle
der solche gefühle wie liebe und so
weiter mit seiner stil einfach nicht
stabil genug sind nicht verbindlich
vielleicht finden wir überhaupt über
einen monat im krach sagt als er meinte
wenn wir vor mir jemanden vorbei auf der
flucht vor einem verbrecher und er
versteckt sich hinter dieser wand und
der verbrecher kommt und sagt ist er
hingelaufen oder
man müsste ich und primat der wahrheit
den vorzug einzurollen uns sagen eher
versteckt sind und wendig aufweist das
versprechen
dahinter liegt in form wenn die
erfassung vorstellen dass das die idee
bekannt gewesen sein sollte dann kommt
in ihren witting schwaz um aufklärung
sorgen für falsch liege komme ich
überhaupt die idee dass unterdessen der
rekordmeister war ausgeübt haben ja das
haben auch viele andere ähnlich gesehen
wie sie und ich habe darüber im letzten
semester und seminare geben den reformen
des unmoralischen und eine seminar- oder
zwei seminar sitzungs orgateam über
diese frage was lügen verbot man kann
das ging und die lüge ich mache es oben
rechts ein link zu dieser seminare
sitzung ein können sich alles
nachschauen habe ich auch aufgenommen
haben viel darüber diskutiert und auf
ihre frage zu antworten kann sagt dass
lügen schlimmer ist eine einzelne lüge
schlimmer ist als wenn ein unschuldiger
verfolgt
durch meine wahrheit aussage durch den
mörder getötet wird
also wenn du durch meine wahrhaftigkeit
ein unschuldiger getötet wird ist es
nicht so schlimm wie wenig gelogen hätte
um sein leben zu retten
was ist der grund was ist der grund dass
kann zeigt die loewes angestimmt werden
für das so jetzt bestehe
er stand sagt das auch ist die frage der
einhaltung
die sechs jahren gemacht und es sind so
recht verstehen setzt das doch bei
demjenigen der das sind ein gesetz
einhalten sollen die kenntnis und wo das
bewusstsein der sünden gesetzesvorhaben
und wenn ich mir vorstelle dass die
philosophie und eine einrichtung des
thik den kontakt zu real existierenden
weltraum sollten stellt sich die frage
hat der mensch der handelt stets das
sind gesetz vor augen und macht weinhefe
allem was entscheidend zb der emotions
passiert entscheidet sagen soll bereits
kommende filme sind und gesetze selbst
was sagt und dann macht mir das nicht
vorstellen wie hier an der realität
verweisen dass wir den fragesteller
erkrankten als seine heimatstadt hinaus
sondern hier aus seinem haus also nicht
die reale welt der menschen die auf der
ersten kunden eine sehr berechtigte
frage wollen sie darauf antworten
und auch das sagen selbst wenn es von
mir
und wenn es ein allgemeines gesetz zur
umgebung oder das leben
das ist einmal genau ist eben die
richtige richtung so den kanten kann ob
die antwort ist etwas contento tief in
these von kann dass wir keinen umständen
lügen dürfen begründet kann so wie soll
ich sagen wenn wir ausnahmsweise nun
dürfte dann würde jeder sich irgendwie
seine ausnahmen zusammensuchen und am
ende hätten wir gar nicht mehr eine
vertrauensbasis auf die wir überhaupt
vernünftig kommuniziert
das heißt kurz gesagt eine einmalige
lüge die zerstörte vertrauen in unsere
vernünftige vertrauensvolle menschen und
das ist bekannt und somit grundlegende
lieben viel schlimmer weil er aus noch
viel schlimmeres entstehen kann also
einfach einfaches beispiel jetzt hier
dass jemand verfolgten dadurch kann er
noch weitere gründe kann zum beispiel ob
jetzt erfolgte wirklich stimmt nicht das
ist ein zufälligkeiten die nichts direkt
mit meine lüge zu tun haben da können
bestimmte umstände eintreten zum
beispiel dass selbst wenn ich das kann
zeigt das beispiel wenn ich jetzt
wahrheit sagen und den mörder von raten
würde wo sich die person befindet meinen
augen dass ich mich dann geht es haben
könnte wo die person ist oder dass die
person mittlerweile wieder wo ganz
anders ist und dass durch meine lüge der
mörder gerade zu dieser person findet
das wären möglich durch zu finden und
kann möchte ihm gar nichts mit zufall zu
tun haben sind sie immer ganz objektiv
wir brauchen wahrhaftigkeit als
grundlage unserer sittlichkeit und jetzt
auf dieser basis gibt es die vertrauen
in institutionen verbindlichkeiten und
ohne diese verbindlichkeit ohne dieses
basis entsteht noch viel schlimmeres als
jetzt in diesem beispielsweise als
selbst wurde schließlich schon eine
freilassung hat gewaltige kraft und die
idee vom spiel zu bringen sondern die
allgemeinheit dass wir allgemeine aktien
das verhalten zu können sind doch gerade
so lauten wäre eine reihe kommen will
einen unbedingten damit ist die allem
[Musik]
aber das wäre eben dann etwas was ad hoc
dazu kommen das wäre eben nichts mehr
weiß ich aus der formalen strukturen aus
dieser absoluten formalen gültigkeit des
sieben gesetzte platzieren könnte
ich kann es nicht aus dieser allgemeinen
so bleiben das möchte kann kann durch
eine ganz einfache regel haben und ihr
vorschlag wäre durch zusatz annahmen und
die verkomplizieren das ganze und zusatz
anlagen sind immer ein bisschen
willkürlich und da kommen wir weg von
diesem einheits prinzip was kann voraus
habe sie haben völlig richtige punkt
angesprochen
wir kommen darauf der nächsten sitzung
weiter zu sprechen jetzt ist leider die
zeit abgelaufen ich muss das seminar
beenden weil ich ein bisschen vor
schluss machen möchte wir haben wichtige
fragen diskutiert wir werden im nächsten
sitzungen darauf eingehen und werden
dann auf fichtes theorie des triebes
übergeht der schauen sie doch mal dieses
muster an der auch hier diesem kontext
die moralphilosophie interessante sachen
sagt der war auch gleichzeitig so ein
bisschen anschluss sucht an kants kritik
der urteilskraft sein wünscht ihr noch